determina la altura de un cilindro de
volumen 16 y por n a la quinta y base
cuyo radio es 12 ok déjame dibujar por
aquí un cilindro para acordarnos de cómo
se calcula su volumen esto de aquí es la
tapa del cilindro es un círculo aquí
tenemos los lados los lados del cilindro
y finalmente voy a dibujar aquí un
cachito de la base es nada más la parte
que se ve bueno es más deja de dibujar
aquí con línea punteada la parte de
atrás indicando que si el cilindro fuera
transparente entonces también se vería
eso bueno pensamos que este cilindro
tiene altura h la altura de este
cilindro es h lo voy a marcar así estoy
aquí es h y pensemos que el área de la
base del cilindro es a va entonces el
área de la base es a
si conocemos la altura y el área de la
base de un cilindro podemos determinar
su volumen multiplicando estas dos
cantidades multiplicando la altura la
altura con el área de la base sin
embargo lo que a nosotros nos piden es
determinar h la altura esto es lo que
nos están preguntando vamos a ver qué
información nos dan a ver pues nos dicen
que el volumen el volumen es de 16 pi es
el color de volumen 16 pn a la quinta
entonces estoy acá es 16 16 y ene a la
quinta y además nos dicen que la base la
base tiene radio 2 en la base es un
círculo verdad bueno la base de la tapa
son iguales son círculos y tienen radio
12 ene pero aquí tenemos el área de la
base
afortunadamente conocemos el área de un
círculo a partir de su radio es de las
primeras cosas que aprendimos en
geometría y tenemos que esa área es
igual a pi pi por radio al cuadrado
entonces vamos a determinar el área de
la base va entonces tenemos
y sabemos que el radio es 12 n entonces
teníamos que poner en vez de r 2 n 2 n
al cuadrado vamos a ver cuánto nos queda
nos quedaría que el área es igual aquí a
ver aquí tenemos que elevar 2 al
cuadrado 2 al cuadrado que es 4 y
multiplicar por n al cuadrado por n al
cuadrado déjame reacomodarlo para que se
vea un poco más bonito lo voy a poner
como 4 y n cuadrado muy bien entonces
esto de aquí es el área de la base ahora
sí podemos encontrar h entonces déjame
escribir la igualdad que tenemos hasta
ahorita tenemos que el volumen que es 16
y por n a la quinta es igual a h lo que
queremos determinar x el área que ya
determinamos x 4 4p n al cuadrado
entonces es un muy buen primer paso para
despejar h eje bueno creo creo que el
único paso para despejar h que tenemos
que hacer es dividir entre 4 y n
cuadrado a ambos lados de esta igualdad
déjame hacer esto voy
aquí entre 4pm cuadrada
4 viene cuadrada de este lado también
voy a dibujar entre 4 y n cuadrada y
vamos a simplificar a ver que nos queda
del lado derecho se cancelan estos dos
términos justo ese fue el chiste de
dividir entre 4 viene cuadrada verdad
entonces del lado derecho simplemente
nos queda h h y nos queda que h es igual
a y vamos a ver si podemos simplificar
lo de la izquierda si podemos
simplificarlo bastantito verdad a ver
mira step y se cancela con éste pib y
entre pies igual a 1 entonces no nos
importa este 16 entre 416 entre 4 es 4
lo voy a cancelar así le voy a poner
queda 4 entonces es 4 por y vamos con la
sen es aquí tenemos n a la quinta
aquí tenemos n al cuadrado podemos
utilizar leyes de los exponentes verdad
si aquí abajo tenemos un exponente
podemos restárselo al exponente de
arriba entonces nos quedaría n a las 5
menos 25 menos 2 estrés entonces sería 4
por n
por n kubica muy bien entonces
determinamos que la altura de nuestro
cilindro es igual a 4 n cúbico